so Jupiter the planet of secret sauce
super sauce enhancement standing next to
the power of destruction creation power
in Capricorn the sign of the government
hmm ah love is being and I am a little
worried just to be perfectly blunt about
this month because it is all of April
where it really escalates now I think
it's great we're all home because the
government is an external reflection of
us assuming someone's got our back you
have your own back so we're reclaiming
our own Capricorn like I'm in charge
this is my job to figure out how I'm
taking care of my family and my food in
my house because we're in quarantine and
we're in this exotics moment Jupiter
conjunct Pluto enhancing the
make-it-or-break-it planet in the sign
of Capricorn our government that can no
longer be externalizing has to be
internalized so are you a governor do
you tell yourself what to eat do you
exercise I have so much fun I I mean I
hate to say I feel bad but I've been so
creative during this insular time
because I said to my Capricorn okay Deb
we're in charge now there's no
government the government is rocking and
rolling Capricorn is being challenged so
I'm gonna say to myself what will I do
with this time well I made a new baby I
had this program called tell me a story
you know about I sent out gifts to my
entire team and wrote look like good
old-fashioned use my colored pens
buttoned did snail mail then I started
cleaning up my entire cover that you can
make this as a governor of my own life
my Capricorn leadership said you your
world needs to be cleaned up now I'm the
outer world it's shaking the government
is not to be trusted by anyone's
feelings safely don't know who to listen
to that is Jupiter conjunct Pluto in
Capricorn the changing of the guards in
the outer world and then we have as you
know Saturn's and Aquarius just entered
and Mars is certainly huh sir two and a
half years all right years but this
month
Mars is standing next to Saturn this
only happens once every two years so
Saturn's at zero degrees of Aquarius and
Mars is at zero degrees Aquarius and
then it moves to one degree then so for
the next three weeks Mars and Saturn
will travel together
Myers is like the warrior he's like he
rules you let's get up and go says Mars
and Saturn is our life lesson it rules
the structure and it's in Aquarius Mars
and Saturn iEARN Aquarius and it's
forcing us to get on the computer to
find another way of relating to humans
and we're doing it lifetime
it's insecure Saturn aquarius means
nothing's gonna be the same everything's
changing it's very scary
but if you lean into faith and that's
what I wanted to finish our podcast with
today if you this is back to when you
asked I loved your question about the
high low high road low road the high
road of Aquarius is that they just had
the most insane sense of trust like they
really do believe in spirit Aquarius
knows we're not just limited to this
reality they know it they live other
words I know so if we as a group and I'd
love to complete our talk today with the
prayer while your heart may be tender
and the fear may be large while you
don't know where the next step is coming
from and how to actually organize for
the future what you do know is the here
and now and in the here and now
nothing's going wrong right this moment
take a deep breath and drop into the
place where you have faith that the
stars are consistent and steady Eddy you
can rely on the Sun and you can rely on
the moon and you can rely on these big
giant planets saying to us we wanted to
teach you a lesson and we didn't know
how to get your attention oh I know
we'll do we'll make them all stay home
well that worked
[Music]
you